[Music]
my first guest tonight plays Glenn on
the hugely popular AMC series The
Walking Dead here's a scene from last
night's season premiere yeah we should
probably go now Bob so stop get him out
of there we'll get the others
[Music]
[Applause]
oh I have to say that was so fantastic
as I know the writers of the show the
producers have been thinking of new ways
to make zombies threaten having them
fall through ceilings on to you guys
it's fantastic nasty was that guy that
was hanging from his entrails the the
I've seen that at Thanksgiving oh I've
seen that that's my brother after like
eight helpings absolutely incredible
congratulations so many people tuned in
last night it's such a success I
understand that you were a little less
than thrilled that you had a shirtless
scene last night and and I would think
what's what's the problem you're right I
just you're in a good-looking guy what's
that I don't know I mean I think it was
like the angle like it was sliced like
this so you could just see my my left
nipple or my yeah and I don't really
have good nipples I've poor I've porn I
don't know what you mean I'm not a
connoisseur of the male nipple yeah I
can't no I don't know what you mean not
whatever wind it to the thing what's
that I look good for Andy tonight
oh yeah but I mean it's like you know
like a normal humans are working with
like a nickel size or like a maybe a
quarter I like it like half time is it
you're self-conscious about the size the
diameter of your nipple there's no way
no one cares about that I think what if
like I'm like called upon to I don't
know in the future we I like have to
breastfeed a baby or something this the
future is coming people and yeah you've
got you know you've got your worries in
the correct priority yeah I'll say that
for you yeah I've never heard a guy it's
not just about his nipples at all I mean
it's just there there I've never even
thought about mine mine are just there
ladies seem to love them and now we've
talked before about your your parents
being kind of a little traditional and
you know maybe a little socially
conservative if that's fair to say how
do they react to I mean you've got some
great on-screen romance let's say I
think you how do they react to your tiny
nipples yeah that's my third question
jumping my second question is no I'm
just curious like how do they react to
you have these live scenes now with you
know it's well it's it's good like my
dad you know I remember he called me
after the last season's in little love
love scene and you and Maggie and Maggie
in the in the in the garage and my dad
calls me he's like he just leaves me a
voicemail he's like Steve you men now
[Laughter]
like the the funny part is like you know
my mom is not wanting to wash yourself
like that and I'm her son but like at
the same time I remember growing up and
I'd be like five are like five to like
eight when she would tuck me into bed
she would pull my hair back all the way
like this and just go because she wanted
a girl so bad she wanted a girl so bad
she would pull my hair back to imagine
what I would look like as a girl I just
just the facial feed you two finally
found someone else's except Conan's mom
would put a wig on seriously she wanted
so she would pretend that you were a
girl yeah I mean like what would happen
is like you know she's in a household of
three annoying men you know yeah guys
and she had dad your brother and she so
she would try and just imagine it had
some psychological effect on you I'm I
don't know I bet you you're worried
about not breastfeeding
comes together